[Music]
chuck you may have heard of
the wave particle duality yes
light
yeah is it a wave or is it a particle
you got waving my particle hey you got
particles in my wave
if you're over 60 you'll get that
reference to a tv commercial
for reese's
reese's peanut butter this is peanut
butter so the problem is we have a brain
that wants to compartmentalize okay and
doesn't really blend to
what feels like disparate bits of
information so people try they invented
the word wavical i thought that was
pretty cool never caught on laval have
you ever heard wavical yeah because yeah
it doesn't work that's why it doesn't
work but let me just give some
uh
interesting examples
it actually sounds like
uh something the professor from the
simpsons whoever called you know
hawaiian play
i'm sorry
all right
so
uh before we pick up wavicle let me just
remind you that light
which in my field we call the
electromagnetic
spectrum
okay
is all forms of light
most familiar to us is visible light
okay red orange yellow green blue violet
okay but if you go on the other side of
red
you get to what
um
infrared infrared very nice the ah your
retina can't detect it but it exists
right we do have infrared sensors it's
we detect it on our skin as heat
all right we can detect infrared but not
we don't see it we feel it though that
by the way
makes us sound so much cooler than we
really are oh without with our skin
sensors we've got infrared sensors yes
yes yes yes yes okay now uh you go
beyond the violet you get what
ultraviolet ultraviolet so that's beyond
the violet we can't see ultraviolet
either
we also have sensors
for ultraviolet but they're
significantly time delayed oh i thought
you meant like black lights that just
show us all the nastiness that happened
in a hotel oh no no that no what happens
in the in under quote black light is
you're you're illuminating the crime
scene with
ultraviolet light which you cannot see
and certain substances fluoresce under
it and send you the light back
in violet light that you can see haha
you're never seeing the ultraviolet
you're never seeing the ultraviolet no
no no no no no no okay so
here we are on ultraviolet we have
ultraviolet sensors they're just time
delayed okay okay time delay is okay
you're out in the sun
oh and an hour later you feel like you
have your sun if you have lighter
colored skin you're you feel like you're
you get sunburned
and you do that enough then you get skin
cancer these are in a way detectors of
ultraviolet it's just too late right
okay right let's go back to the other
end uh so we had red infrared and you
keep going in that direction on the
spectrum by the way what's changing on
the spectrum is the wavelength of the
light
okay so as we go to the red wavelengths
are getting bigger and bigger we get to
ultra we get to infrared beyond
infrared we get to microwaves micro yeah
okay so now i can describe the the
length of the wave like with physical
fingers and things so a
microwave is like a few millimeters to
like
maybe a couple of centimeters around wow
let's just call it a centimeter yeah a
physical centimeter that's that's a
pretty big weight that's a big wave
that's a half an inch and so a full wave
a crest and a trough gets manifested in
that space when you have microwaves okay
nice okay let's go beyond that you get
to what we call radio waves right
so
[Music]
before microwaves had their own name
they were just short wavelength radio
waves
okay
okay so then we said well there's small
versions of radio waves let's call them
microwaves and that's why they have
they're called micro
even though they're bigger than infrared
right all right that's all i'm saying
here okay
so so radio waves are like meters
and longer we don't have words
a radio wave can be miles in wavelength
we don't have a different word for that
so
radio waves are for everything bigger
than microwaves
all right so now watch if i want to
detect a radio wave
i need a thing
that's at least as big as one of the
waves
gotcha
so
tv
old world tv
before it came in via cable
used antennae
how long was a tv antenna
um two stories
the one on your tv
exactly was about a meter long right
yeah okay in fact you'd have two of them
sticking out all over the place and
you'd extend it to about the length of
the waves of the of the radio waves
you're trying to receive
okay
all i'm saying is you can't detect waves
bigger than the size of your detector it
doesn't work okay okay it'll just wash
over your detector and your detector
won't even know what happened right so
how about microwaves have you ever seen
a microwave um
walkie-talkies
how long is the antenna on a microwave
walkie-talkie ah you know it's about
like that there's nothing to it it's
about it's about it's like an inch and a
half
there's your microwaves
that's the size of the microwaves that's
pretty wild
that's that's so it it is the size to
fit the situation
right okay that also means
if you have a substance that prevents
the transmission
of any of this energy okay you could put
holes in it and as long as the holes are
smaller than the wave the wave is not
going to get through
whoa
that
is that uh like
so take a look at your microwave oven
that's what i was about to say that's
right so the microwaves so white
microwaves go through glass no problem
gotcha all right so
but
so you have a glass thing so microwaves
and visible light go through so you can
see your food cooking but there's
something else on the other side there's
a screen screen
and that screen is opaque to microwaves
okay
except they put holes in it
now that's why i got this tumor on my
head you know what you stop is that
just don't stick your head inside the
microwave
so
so
neither you nor the microwaves can see
through that material except for the
fact that they put holes in the material
right how big are the holes
tiny they're smaller than the size of
the microwaves they're using in that
oven that's pretty wild microwaves
cannot it's the antenna in reverse in
reverse oh i like that very clever
very clever so
so
so you can put holes in things so radio
telescopes
have you ever seen a radio telescope go
to a radio telescope one day they're
huge and they're made of like mesh
they're like chicken wire mesh with
these huge holes in it because it's
depending on which kind of radio
telescope you're visiting that the the
the metal is reflective of radio waves
but you don't have to build the whole
surface
of metal you can put big holes in it
makes it lighter all right and rain can
get through and not a problem and with
because of these huge dishes and they
can take radio waves reflect them to a
focus
and there you have it
that is uh really really cool well let's
keep going in the other direction okay
okay there's more
but wait there's more okay i was
satisfied but yes all right please let's
go let's go the other direction so we
got a red orange yellow green blue
violet ultra violet you go beyonce you
have x-rays x-rays wavelengths are
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller okay
really tiny tiny tiny tiny
much smaller than the wavelengths for
visible light
all right so now watch
if i have a regular microscope
and i want to see something small
i cannot see anything smaller
than the wavelength
of the violet light i'm using in the
visible spectrum
oh man
because otherwise it washes right over
it would not even know it's there right
okay
so if you want to see things smaller
then the wavelength of visible light
that would be the violet side of it you
need even smaller wavelengths of light
interesting
so so here's talk about getting clever
you ready
so people said
how about electrons
right you say well electrons are
particles they're not waves they're also
waves oh my gosh what wavelength
corresponds to electrons that we could
generate in the machine
x-rays
oh my gosh
so electrons and x-rays have the same
wavelength wow
so if i invent a microscope that uses
electrons
then i'm using a wavelength of light
as small
as
x-rays so i can see the tiniest detail
so the photographs that have this the
most exquisite detail of the smallest
things are not regular microscope
photographs
they're electron microscopes
because we
we
we what do you call it we co-opted we
commandeered electrons
piggybacked an electron
using the
x-ray wavelength that it represents
to take that's where you see those bug
pictures with the hairs and right things
the bacteria all this there you go
that is
fascinating
that that's that's that and that's how
electron microscopes work that's how
they were isn't it clever of the human
mind to do that after quantum physics we
said we got the wave particle duality
and i can't see anything smaller than
the wavelength of violet light but i
know there's got to be detail there
because there's detail up until the
point where it gets fuzzy right well let
me keep going and then you invent the
electron microscope and bada bing the
world of of the small continues to open
to you so that means if so is our gam
what's the smallest wave is it gamble so
the smallest uh waves that we have a
word for are gamma rays so gamma rays
are like are the opposite
like radio waves so it's smaller
wavelengths than x-rays or gamma rays
and then we don't have it we don't keep
dividing it so
so gamma rays that are like really
really really small they're still
they're still called gamma rays yes okay
so the problem is if you a gamma ray
telescope you have to be able to focus
it
okay it's not good enough just to use
the light yeah you need to be clever
about with the machine you're making and
we know how to focus electrons because
they have a charge right so we can focus
them down and get images and things so
yeah
so the only thing uh gamma rays are good
for is making you a superhero hulk yeah
yeah that's that's tested we we know
right we know that
and i think it's gamma rays on the on
spider-man too
if um i don't know i'm not sure what it
is it was a radioactive spider it was a
radioactive spider that bit him
and i don't i'm not sure what ra what
what what kind of a machine was using to
make him
you know first of all i just love that
we went from
pure science here's how an electron
microscope works to
now exactly uh how the spider-man
and this is how you become the hulk
how you become your basement
so all i'm saying is check your
microwave oven if your holes are the
size of like a centimeter they're too
big and microwaves are leaking out
right if they're down around a
millimeter or two then that's a good
size you're not getting the mic the
microwaves are not getting out there you
go there you go you don't want to end up
with a tumor on your head like chuck
nice see what do you do what what why
are you white that tmi
so what's going on on your forehead oh
no now i had a concussion some time ago
and this i have to get this surgically
removed so it's it's there now and it
won't go away
okay all right and my wife did it
maybe i may have buried the lead but
[Laughter]
it's all right so that's a little bit on
size and wavelengths that you might not
have known a connection that you might
not have known was ever there that was
great this is star talk we did some
explaining today neil degrasse tyson
keep looking up
[Music]